i argue in the book that there's a
loosely affiliated
conglomeration of
businesses
law firms
media outlets
corporations
and academic institutions that are all
sort of working together to push this
and there's a lot of money behind it one
really great source of information for
this is called the 11th hour blog
and the author of that blog goes into an
astonishing degree of detail regarding
the money that is fueling this
so
it is just not the case which we have
been told that transgender is a coherent
category of people who are just fighting
for their civil rights it's just not
true it is a very top-heavy very heavily
funded uh top-down movement to abolish
sex throughout society and people have
bought it i don't know why people have
bought it i'm as mystified as you are um
but a lot of people haven't and i hear
from people on social media and on email
frequently from the political left
saying how did this happen i'm not going
along with this and so that's really
good uh but again the media won't
platform our voices and so
lefties democrats uh feminists gay
rights activists all over the country
feel very isolated because they think
they're alone they like you have friends
who say this is fine we should just go
along with this and people all over the
country are thinking why is this fine
but they think they're alone and so
they're afraid to say something
so how could this possibly be making
anybody money
so one example is john striker he
is um he founded something called the
arcus foundation he's a very wealthy man
he's a billionaire and he founded
something called the arcus foundation
which hands out grants multi-million
dollar grants to fund this it they
literally give money to fund this yes
and uh mr striker is also
heir to a medical supply company so if
you started connecting yeah yeah
you connected that dot pretty quickly
oh no okay so can you connect that dot
for anybody listening who hasn't
connected that dot what kind of medical
supply chain what did
what is he heavily invested in
so the medical supply entrance industry
stands to gain a lot of money and earn a
lot of profit by
conducting cosmetic surgeries on
confused children and young people
we can't omit pharma pharma of course
makes a ton of profit from putting a
generation's worth of children and young
people on a lifetime's worth of hormones
that is
terrifying but
also completely makes sense